let's talk about Kim Kardashian now for
those of you that don't know I'm I don't
know how you can be an American and not
know who Kim Kardashian is but Kim
Kardashian is a billionaire or close to
it right she has been in social media
for you know our entire lives basically
and about 10 15 years ago she married
Kanye West so Kanye and Kim went public
with their romance in 2012. so they
started dating in 2012 this is over 10
years ago
recently um about a year ago year and a
half they announced their divorce
now you know a lot of people would label
Kim Carr or Kanye as crazy
okay
and you know maybe maybe he he maybe is
a bit eccentric whatever but Kim
Kardashian
she had like a new boyfriend immediately
after all this whatever whatever so they
moved on whatever
and in the new
um series
Kim talks about her divorce why don't we
bring up the clip you're okay not okay
it's so different than the person that I
married I just can't that's who I loved
and that's who I remember
they'll be like Pearl Pearl how do you
know the man won't just switch up when
we're married and this is what I say is
that oftentimes women will marry a man
and he shows you exactly who he is and
then women want to whine later about
their choices so what happened
um Kim marries Kanye and towards the end
of the relationship a big stress was
Kanye being very eccentric he would post
tweets about their marriage and they
were very public that this was a very
hard time in their marriage so
how could he just switch up and publicly
blast out all their information Kanye
was never eccentric except roll the clip
with the breach of three levees
protecting New Orleans the landscape of
the city has changed dramatically
tragically and perhaps irreversibly
there's now over 25 feet of water where
there was once city streets and thriving
neighborhoods
I hate the way they betray us and the
media if you see a black family it says
they're looting see a white family and
says they're looking for food and you
know it's been five days because most of
the people
are black and even for me to complain
about I would be a hypocrite because
I've tried to turn away from the Teacher
TV because it's too hard to watch I've
even been shopping before even giving a
donation so now I'm calling my business
manager right now to see what's what is
the biggest amount I can give and and
just to imagine if I was if I was down
there and those are those are my people
down there so anybody out there that
wants to do anything that we can help
with with the setup the way America is
set up to help the um uh the poor the
the black people the uh the less
well-off as slow as possible I mean this
is Red Cross is doing everything they
can we already realized a lot of the
people that could help r at War right
now fighting another way and they
they've given them permission to go down
and shoot us
and subtle but in even many ways more
profoundly devastating is the lasting
damage to the survivor's will to rebuild
and remain in the area the destruction
of the spirit of the people of Southern
Louisiana and Mississippi may end up
being the most tragic loss of all George
Bush doesn't care about black people
that was Kanye West hold the next clip
pull the next clip
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time
one of the best videos of all time
this is what I mean
when women will pick a guy with certain
traits and qualities this is a date on
Kanye you guys know I am a big yay fan I
think he's hilarious but if you're gonna
date a guy like that you know what
you're getting yourself into he's always
been eccentric he's always been the type
to just say it how it is publicly okay
so am I are we shocked are we shocked
that he does crazy stuff later when he's
always done crazy stuff but this is what
I mean women will pick a guy it will be
very obvious the type of guy he is and
then they will whine and complain about
the outcome and then break up their
family after they get the kids
so this is why I have no sympathy this
is why I have no sympathy okay
nobody's perfect everybody has pros and
cons of them and you should just know
the type of guy you're dealing with and
if you can't pick for yourself I would
find you know a brother uncle or father
because as women we just pick stupidly
they can help us okay but that's the
crazy thing it's like women will be with
the most world-renowned Superstar of all
time and still complain like what does
he not have he's got money status Fame
all the things that modern women
typically look for and still
She's Gotta divorce him just like the
modern women way